i want to talk to you if i may russell
about
audible original revelation connecting
with the sacred
uh in everyday life uh i wondered if
and when you were going to bring that up
because as you know i'm obligated
to promote that not that i consider it
to be any great chore i was willing to
take the money
i enjoyed writing the audible original i
was happy to
read it out in the booth and as it turns
out everything i said i believed in
is meant to be an exploration of the
sacred but you're the professional
you're the man behind the desk in front
of an electric
organ of some description please
guide me through this topic as you've
done so many times
still yet without betraying any sign of
world weariness
um i my soul died a long time ago
russell and uh it actually my soul left
my body on camera
in 2002. um you can actually see the
episode where it leaves
um i believe i was talking to david
hasselhoff and it just left
uh has never returned but i want to talk
to you about this because
i think it's a great mix of the serious
and the silly
i think you you you take this uh to
heart
this search for truth one of the things
that you wanted to do
pre-pandemic to help promote
this audible original was to go out into
the world and try things
experience things you wanted to take
ayahuasca
is that true i'm in recovery from drugs
and alcohol
one day at a time for over 18 years
i think it has become clear in the world
conan now
that materialism and post-enlightenment
rationalism
is no longer providing us with the
solutions we need to everyday life this
is why there is so much division take
this time of pandemic
where the stated objective is to somehow
return to normal
it's a normal in inverted commerce that
many many people were deeply
dissatisfied with
the fissures and fractures in both of
our nations are
evidence of how unhappy people have been
for a long time and while superficially
we may be squabbling about
borders boundaries walls
even serious subjects such as race or
gender or sex
i think that all of this is in fact a
reference to a deeper spiritual
malaise like many people i think uh
cultures that have retained a connection
to mystery sometimes through shamanism
may have answers that we ourselves need
to access at this time
the problem is i've burned all my drug
bridges
even if they're lovely cozy drug bridges
taken you know psilocybin
or stuff taken in a jungle in a complex
way with a shaman
i can't do it right i'd like you to do
it
and to to vicariously experience the
giddy thrills of hallucigens
perhaps what you're proposing is that
because you are
in recovery and congratulations on that
that's that's uh a great achievement
because you're in recovery what you'd
like to do
is have me take ayahuasca and you
observe me and
see how i react and that will give you
the necessary information you need is
that right
all i need is for you to wear a simple
humble body glove
for us to be neurologically connected
through a series of sticky patches
so that i see what you see and i feel
what you feel
it's the body glove too great a request
to make of you
i mean like the psychedelic world is not
the only way to experience revelation
revelation and epiphany are encountered
and experienced everywhere
we were all looking for something but i
think it's the body glove which is
selling
me on it most for us listen to me
russell were you to see me
in a very tight form-fitting body glove
body glove you would experience quite a
revelation i promise you
hello old friend
[Laughter]
you know i um i would do that for you i
i'm very fond of you uh i'm a big fan of
yours and i would happily
take this uh this
i would take an ayahuasca i would i
would do it
i don't even know what it is i'm very
straight studies have revealed
conan but psilocybin the active
psychedelic agreement in
ingredients excuse me in magic mushrooms
is as effective in treating depression
as the best pharmaceutical depression
drugs that there are
i've been fascinated in this i mean as i
say for me as a person in recovery it's
a sort of it's uh
like it's something that i have to be
extremely cautious about but
you as a man who sacrificed his soul
tonight ryder decades ago
you've got very little to lose
you work you are right that i can only
go
i can only go up from here from where i
am you're looking at
a husk of a man a dried-out husk a man
who gave everything he had to american
television for close to
30 years and um how have i been repaid
uh to be mocked by a man lying in bed
on on a british isle that uh that uh
you know our people fled uh hundreds of
years ago
um this is my fate now this is what i
must be subjected to
is you you laughing at me in bed
it's other realms that hold the solution
for
you and i conan the material world the
late night world
it's given you all it has to offer it
has nothing else to give you it can only
take
from you now it can only continue to
suck at your grey
presumably noodle length nipple again
and again
dragging at that whimpering duck that
has
no further yields no further yields
conan
you trust now
[Laughter]
did you just refer to my breast
as a doug i mean i think no one's done
that since t ts
eliot that was my hat my my virtual hat
is off to you
my presumably noodle-like
gray doug that's fantastic
the english people have not held an
american in such high regard since t.s
eliot
came to this country and right near to
where i live right now as a matter of
fact to write some of his greatest
poetry yeah i think i think conan
look this is what i truly believe and
the fact is is that um in it i'm
like the original intention was to go on
a sort of yes perhaps potentially
psychedelic journey certainly to me
shaman neurologists and geniuses of
every description in order to discover
what is it
what is it that's going to fulfill us
now now that we
the we know that the material world
cannot quench us now that we know
technology is not going to
provide us the answer particularly not
to technology in the hands of the same
people that have deployed the mindset
that has led us to the precipice where
we now find ourselves
therefore an investigation into the
sacred the re-sacralizing of the
everyday
make our relationship with one another
sacred make our communities sacred
make even our haircuts and our crystal
wands sacred this is surely the answer
so
i couldn't do that though because
obviously you know the pandemic if i got
locked up travel got banned
so i sort of just simply had to go on a
journey of reflection and introspection
but there was so there was still i i was
able to discover the sacred through this
through the death of friends through the
death of my dear beloved recently
reincarnated in kitten form so i don't
know i mean there is a reincarnation
because it's another life but i'll show
you the evidence i mean you may think i
sound mad but i can show you the kitten
as i often find myself saying in court
like
do you are you saying that you lost
someone and that you believe they've
been reincarnated as a kitten
it's not as crazy as it sounds because
it was a cat in the first place
oh and in fact i can show you this well
wait yes
a cat coming back as another cat what's
that all about
it's not a game show it's not like
you're trying to live as much it's not
like doctor do little carousel or i was
a cat now i'm a dog now i'm a horse now
i'm a lizard
now i'm a boy child with a twinkle in
the eye now i'm a wandering minstrel
the idea is just that we're on some
limitless wheel
of the non-material world is realizing
itself through material there are
subtler frequencies making himself
manifest through matter and if that's a
problem for you
conan i will simply provide the kitten
and put this matter to bed
once and for all okay let's see this
amazing creature
that died as a cat and came back
as another cat that that
we may live that we may live oh my god
and you know when it's going on easter
as well you're descending into your own
mind right now you're lost
ladies ages we must venture into the
underworld
the retrieve the boom how else are we to
retrieve the moon without a gentleman
i give you i'll give you exhibit this is
one so let's put this argument about
reincarnation which is a sacred belief
to the hindus let's face it and uh
and uh if you don't believe that that's
a serious matter talk to hank azaria
now here oh yeah is a depiction by
noel fielding the great british comedian
of
my cat morrissey here is a further
depiction by another artist he was much
beloved
artists couldn't they couldn't get
enough of him they were always
depicting him this is by david lynch and
it's a
it's a drawing of what he says limitless
consciousness looks like and if
you if you can follow that you should
probably try watching one of his films
now here is what beneath this humble
blanket
is the answer to life's great mysteries
conan when i draw back the veil
prepare to be dazzled because this
ordinary bengal cat
oh see now you see how look at that it's
gorgeous
oh how many oh they're beautiful are
they so lovely and look at her she
doesn't know
she doesn't know she's on tps and there
could be a dozen people watching this
right now
well that's quite optimistic it doesn't
shook them by now russell uh
maybe maybe on the youtube if we tweet
about you we don't worry about those
things those are material concerns that
i don't worry about
meaningless equals vanity who cares
this is the moment it doesn't matter if
people watch it or not it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter all our all our
graves go unattended
you know that's what i say we uh weeds
grow over our tombstones who cares
enjoy the next dust on the wind of
history conan
here we are trying to make how talk
shows work and our audible original cell
and for what
this did christ on the cross did cat
jesus come back on easter monday by the
way
just so that we could squander our
precious time here pursuing ratings
which one is the reincarnated morrissey
well he's actually on the nipple now and
i'm reluctant to
remove him because it seems cruel but i
will do it because you know this is
otherwise the bit doesn't have a natural
conclusion so you know i've still got a
producer's mind even though i only work
very well
the bit has to have a finish uh that's
one of the sacred
uh that's one of the sacred truisms of
the universe
it does you can't yeah if there's a
rifle oh sorry i felt him come off of
the nipple there that was um i
felt wrong that's morrissey behold cat
jesus he has risen
and i'm not making a mocker of
christianity there by the way just you
know you saw the pictures by noel
fielding
you saw the drawings by lynch you see
this cat you see that all the others
are bengal looking and here he is
where is in the good go back go back
it's a shame we can't offer him your
little noodle nip to have a little suck
on see if you can't get the last bit of
bay watches
titty juice you've gone
you know this in our country about 50
years ago we had a saying
you've gone crackers man you've flipped
you've you've lost it you've gone mad
you've got you
i get excited sometimes by you and by
you encourage me and this is always a
problem
at school and as a heroin addict if
people encouraged me
i would take more heroin until the point
where i sometimes felt quite unwell
yeah well i'm glad those days are behind
you now i'm glad
you seem happy uh you seem comfortable
you seem centered and at peace um i've
loved
i've loved seeing your home i'd love to
visit in person one day
when that's allowed yes i would love
that i would certainly have you here
you're a very
tall person with in a sense no need
to make themselves a follicular bonnet
but you've done that nonetheless but
you you would fit in our humble
cottage and we would very much love to
take care of you if we
could mr o'brien i mean we would offer
our finest gruel
why did we suddenly go into a dickens
novel um
i don't know i felt i was uncomfortable
with sincerity i know
i'm sure it's a feeling you must well
i'm gonna make sure i get the word out
revelation
connecting with the sacred in everyday
life is available now exclusively on
audible uh russell i say this with
sincerity
um i can't think of who i enjoy talking
with more it's always pyrotechnic
uh beautifully strange uh and i
it's i i'm always in heaven when we're
babbling our foolishness and uh so thank
you if you made my day i really
appreciate it and i hope that i made
your night
because you're in england right now
that's right and yeah you're
a valuable person in my life and i hope
i get to see you when i'm next over
there
and our door is always open to you not
literally that would be a security risk
but metaphorically consider it open
well russell brand thank you very very
much this was very nice and
i think now you should just slip off to
sleep you know i think you should close
your eyes
just drift off to sleep i'm beginning to
think that these are my last precious
moments alive and this is the vision
that will present me as i pass into the
next life
goodbye
[Laughter]
go to the light russell go to the light
lights never look more attractive you
will be reincarnated as
russell brand
[Laughter]
yeah wow man crazy